cómo están las noticias económicas este
jueves 10 de septiembre bienvenidos a
esta sección con la especialista daniel
a blandón daniela empezamos hablando de
europa y es que ahí están mejorando las
perspectivas económicas bueno si hablan
muy buenas noches pues el banco central
europeo- es modestamente optimista sobre
la recuperación de la región que
recordemos cayó en una recesión
histórica a medida que se van reabriendo
las actividades turísticas industriales
y comerciales la economía va mejorando a
pesar del temor por la segunda ola de
contagios las decisiones de la junta del
banco central hoy fueron dos primero
seguir comprando deuda por tiempo
indefinido y segundo mantener las tasas
de interés en un mínimo del 0 por ciento
de pasos redujo su estimación de
contracción económica para este año que
antes era del 87 %
estas proyecciones prevén un crecimiento
anual del pib real de menos de 8% en
2020 del 5% en 2021 y del 3,2 por ciento
en 2022
ripoll sant en tuenti institute seguimos
el continente daniela y es que el break
se sigue agitando el debate político en
londres y en bruselas bueno que concluyó
sin avances tal y como se esperaba la
octava ronda de negociaciones del
acuerdo comercial del break sheet el
negociador de la unión europea michel
barnier dijo que a pesar de que ha
habido flexibilidad en las demandas
británicas por ejemplo en el tema de la
pesca londres parece no estar
comprometido esto se da en momentos en
que el primer ministro boris johnson
desafió a bruselas con una posible
ruptura del acuerdo de divorcio un plan
del que la unión europea le pide de
existir si no quiere irse a instancias
legales pues así le respondió el reino
unido
le expliqué al vicepresidente de la
comisión europea que no podíamos ni
haríamos eso algunos han argumentado que
esta legislación es un intento de anular
de alguna manera el acuerdo de retirada
o de eludir la implementación del
protocolo para nada no
dejamos europa y es que en cuba hay
expectativa por una posible devaluación
del tipo de cambio daniela a la
propuesta sería una unificación
monetaria a partir del primero de
octubre es decir que un peso cubano
tenga el mismo valor que un dólar lo que
implicaría la primera devaluación desde
la revolución de 1959 esta es una
información que ha venido circulando por
redes sociales y medios locales y que
agencias como reuters ya la dan por
cierto sin embargo el banco central de
cuba dice que no es así en este momento
a la para que entendamos hay dos monedas
legales en cuba' el peso cubano y el
peso convertibles se supone que este
último vale lo mismo que un dólar aunque
a veces vale un poco menos debido a la
crisis de divisas y para comprar un peso
convertibles se necesitan 24 pesos
cubanos así que finalmente estas monedas
quedarían unificadas si el gobierno
confirma esta noticia muy bien daniel
avalos eeuu y es que una popular cadena
minorista de rebajas en nueva york
cierra sus puertas no sé si usted estará
de acuerdo conmigo alan en que una de
las paradas casi obligadas para muchos
turistas de la gran manzana ha sido por
décadas
tradicional cadena minorista centro y tú
en igual que ofrece rebajas en artículos
de moda y cosmética pues esta empresa
acaba de declararse en la quiebra y dijo
que cerrará sus trece almacenes
distribuidos en nueva york nueva jersey
pensilvania y florida se terminan así 60
años de historia del centro y tony wang
y se suma a otras que también se han
declarado en bancarrota por culpa de la
pandemia como por ejemplo brooks
brothers que es la marca más antigua de
ropa en el país y otros como jake club
en taylor o los grandes almacenes jazzy
pene monos con los indicadores si te
parece bien empezamos a sí mismo de eeuu
1 wall street devolvió a las pérdidas y
las tecnológicas vuelven a ser las
culpables como apple que bajó más del 3
por ciento las bolsas europeas también
bajaron aunque ligeramente tras las
reuniones del banco central europeo que
no trajo grandes sorpresas para el
mercado y en américa latina no hubo
grandes cambios a excepción del fuerte
descenso en la bolsa de sao paulo
para finalizar daniela cuáles las cifras
del día bueno la cifra voy a dejar que
sea usted o que sean los televidentes
los que la pongan porque mítica la casa
de subastas del software vice pondrá a
la venta el próximo 5 de octubre en hong
kong un diamante de 102 quilates que
dice es extremadamente raro como usará
de costoso alan que la casa de subastas
no se ha atrevido a ponerle un precio
inicial a la subasta
sino que dejará que lo defina el mercado
para que ustedes se hagan una idea y
para que calculen más o menos el último
diamante que se vendió a costó 22
millones de dólares y eso que era de
menor calidad cuánto daría usted alan
por este diamante y vaya si el otro era
22 millones de dólares pues sólo
podremos comprar uno daniel entonces sí
señor muchas gracias por este recorrido
económico y muchas gracias por su
compañía ya lo sabe vea más mucho más en
france 24 punto com
[Música]